ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER.
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON RIO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER HIM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG USER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON IN --
WHEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
WE MODE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAY [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ROBERT REAVIS [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WORD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
[inaudible]
IT'S A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS WEEKEND THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS WILL PACE THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS IN SUPER BOWL.
FIFTY THREE IT IS INTERESTING
HOW THE GAMES WE HAVE CREATED
CAN ALSO GIVE US A PERSPECTIVE
ON LIFE.
WHEN SINCE TO PLAY IN THE
SUPERBOWL IS THE FULFILLMENT OF
A PROFESSIONAL FOOTBALL PLAYERS
DREAM? FOR ESPECIALLY THE
PLAYERS AND COACHES OF THE RAMS
AND PATRIOTS ALL THAT THEY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THE ENTIRE SEASON.
COMES DOWN TO THE SIXTY MINUTES
OF THIS ONE GAME [inaudible]
IN LIFE.
WE MAY HAVE MORE GENES BUT IT IS
RARE TO HAVE ONE SO CLEARLY
DEFINED.
HOWEVER LIKE LIFE WHEN THE GAMES
BEGIN THERE IS NO GUARANTEE OF
WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE.
LIKE OUR LIVES ARE EFFORT TO
PURSUE EXCELLENCE COUPLED WITH
THE DECISIONS WE MAKE WE DO NOT
MAKE.
THE ACTIONS WE TAKE OR DID NOT
TAKE.
WILL PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN
SHAPING WHO WE ARE AND WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF OUR LIVES WILL BE.
YES THIS THE TEAM SAID SUNDAY
EACH AND EVERY PLAY.
WE CAN ONLY TRY TO LIVE OUR VERY
BEST EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND AS I'VE OFTEN SHARED.
IF WE TRY OUR BEST TO LIVE EACH
MOMENT WELL.
IN TIME WE CANNOT HELP BUT LOOK
BACK ON A LIFE WELL LIVED.
DO YOU FEEL WE HAVE HAD A LIFE
WELL LIVED.
IS A DREAM WORTHY OF PURSUING
WITH OUR VERY BEST EFFORT.
NUMBER ONE THEM WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER FRAZIER MEMBERS AND
GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN IN OUR
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO OUR FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible] TO IS A LITTLE.
SLOW.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JANUARY
NINTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THESE WOMEN AT SEVEN AM THE
ANIMAL STEVEN CHOI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIXTY TO PROVIDE YOU FOR
PRODUCTION WAS NOT DESPERATE IN
PROGRAMMING MOVES READING.
OF LONG TERM BONTA MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL [inaudible]
MR.
CONTACT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE. ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
A FOR THE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK.
CHIU EDUARDO GARCIA AND AS THEY
ARE IN TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY
BOTH IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLERY.
MEMBERS IF YOU'LL PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY [inaudible]
VERSE.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER
KILEY.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS HONOR TO
TODAY RECOGNIZED THE FOLSOM HIGH
SCHOOL BULLDOGS A FOOTBALL TEAM
LIKE NO OTHER WHO RECENTLY
CAPTURED THEIR SECOND STRAIGHT
DIVISION ONE DOUBLE WAY.
CALIFORNIA STATE FOOTBALL
CHAMPIONSHIP AND THEIR FOURTH
CHAMPIONSHIP.
IN THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
GIVEN THE LEVEL OF COMPETITION
IN HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL'S
PREMIER DIVISION THIS
ACHIEVEMENT IS NOTHING SHORT OF
ASTONISHING.
AND THIS YEAR'S CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME WHICH CAPPED A DOMINANT
FOURTEEN IN ONE SEASON SHOWED
WHAT BULLDOG FOOTBALL IS ALL
ABOUT.
AFTER FALLING BEHIND IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER FULSOME BATTLE
BACK WITH THE HEART OF A
CHAMPION.
TYING THE GAME TO FORCE OVERTIME.
IN THE EXTRA PERIOD THE BULLDOG
OFFENSE DELIVERED WITH A
SEVENTEEN YARD TOUCHDOWN PASS
FOLLOWED BY A STRONG DEFENSE OF
STAND TO CLINCH THE VICTORY.
IN ADDITION TO WINNING THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP THE TEAM ALSO
FINISHED THE YEAR RANKED NUMBER
SEVEN IN THE NATION. NINETEEN
FOR SOME HIGH PLAYERS WERE NAMED
TO THE SACRAMENTO BEE'S ALL
METRO TEAM.
AND TWENTY ONE PLAYERS WERE
SELECTED FOR SIERRA FOOTHILLS
ALL LEAGUE TEAM BUT EACH AND
EVERY FIRE CAN TAKE A NOR MISS
PRIDE.
IN THE HEART DETERMINATION AND
TEAM SPIRIT THAT MADE THIS
SEASON SUCH A SPECTACULAR
SUCCESS.
AND OF COURSE NONE OF THIS WOULD
BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION A FULSOME
FOOTBALLS OUTSTANDING COACHES.
THE CITY A FOR SOME IS SO PROUD
OF THIS TEAM.
AND THIS TEAM IT MEANS SO MUCH
TO THE FULL SOME COMMUNITY.
WITH ME TODAY ON THE FLOOR ARE
TEAM CAPTAINS KATE IN RICHARDSON.
TYLER HARDAMON PARKER CLAYTON
AND DILLON GEORGE AS WELL AS
COACHES JIM NOBLE JUSTIN
PETERSON BRAD FALLS INTO
MCCANDLESS AND DISTRICT ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR PETER MAROON.
REST OF THE TEAM IS WITH US IN
THE GALLERY.
I ASKED MY FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. TO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
THE STATE CHAMPION PULL SOME
BOTOX
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY SECOND READING.
CORPORATE SO WE WILL SEND YOU TO
THE MEMBERS INNOCENTLY BILLS
EVERY THREE MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ITEM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP ON
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE ACR THIRTEEN THE COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO
FRED KOREMATSU DAVE CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND THE CONSTITUTION.
MISTER KANSEN CHU HE MAY OPEN ON
THE RESOLUTION.
CHECK YOU MISTER SPEAKERS AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO INTRODUCE AC
ARE THIRTEEN WHICH RECOGNIZED
JANUARY THIRTIETH TWENTY
NINETEEN AS FRET CAR.
DAY OF CIVIL LIBERTY LIBERTY AND
THE CONSTITUTION.
MISTER FRED KOREMATSU WAS ONE OF
AMERICANS GREAT THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST.
HE'S KNOWN FOR BOLDLY
CHALLENGING THE UNJUST.
PERSECUTION AND DISCRIMINATION
OF JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING THE
PERIOD OF THE JAPANESE INTERMENT
IN OUR COUNTRY.
HE WAS ARRESTED ON MAY THIRTIETH
NINETEEN FORTY TWO AND CHARGE
WAS VIOLATING THE MANDATORY
EXCLUSION OLDER.
ON NOVEMBER TENTH NINETEEN SIX
SUCCESSFULLY FOUGHT HIS
CONVICTION.
AND GOD THAT OVERTURN.
THIS LED TO THE PASSAGE OF CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT M. MISTER KALRA MOST WHO
WAS AWARDED THE PRESIDENT MEDAL
OF FREEDOM.
ON JANUARY FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT DURING WORLD WAR
TWO OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
THIS IN JAPANESE AMERICANS WERE
IMPRISONED AND FORCED TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES DUE TO THEIR
HERITAGE.
THIS OCCURRED BECAUSE ALL BROUGH
RATE RACIAL PREJUDICE AS A FOR A
FELLOW WHO IN POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP [inaudible]
OUR BRETT.
IN IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HONOR
THE GREAT CONTRIBUTION OF MISTER
PRATT.
CARL MUST YOU MADE FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND ACKNOWLEDGED A LESSON
LEARNED FROM HIS TIME IN HISTORY
SO THAT WE DO NOT REPEAT THEM.
AS IN IN THE FUTURE I ASK THE
FIRST ROW TO BE OPENED VOCAL
AUTHOR AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER JUNE.
MISS POWER QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF
THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO
SUPPORT ACR.
THIRTEEN RECOGNIZING JANUARY
THIRTIETH AS FRED KOREMATSU DAY
OF CIVIL LIBERTIES AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
MISTER KOREMATSU RESTS THE
MOUNTAIN VIEW CEMETERY IN
OAKLAND NEAR WHERE MY OLDEST SON
WAS BORN.
WE WOULD GO ON WALKS TO HIS
GRAVE TO HONOR HIM AND LEARN
FROM HIM TO BE A BRAVE FIGHTER
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
EVEN IF IT TAKES YOU ALL THE WAY
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
FRED KOREMATSU EMBODIED STRENGTH.
THAT WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
TODAY.
STRENGTH TO STAND AGAINST A
FEDERAL WHO DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS BASED ON
THEIR NATIONAL ORIGIN OR
RELIGION.
STRENGTH TO ADVOCATE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES FOR ALL
PEOPLE.
MISTER KOREMATSU DID NOT GET
JUSTICE IN HIS LIFETIME.
BUT WE MUST WORK TO CARRY ON HIS
LEGACY AND SEE THAT HIS DREAM
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY IS
FULFILLED.
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MILPITAS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR.
THIRTEEN MISTER MURATSUCHI YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE. FOR
A AND BRING IN THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FOR MISTER SPEAKER
MASS FOR SOME ORDER IN THE HOUSE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THAT'S SPEAKER WE ARE ALL
JOINING GO OUR COLLEAGUE BUT TO
TO FROM.
SAN JOSE AND RECOGNIZING ONE OF
THE GREAT CIVIL RIGHTS HEROES OF
OUR COUNTRY BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS NOT JUST.
AN ISSUE FROM THE PAST.
JUST LAST YEAR IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT.
IF VOTE THE KOREMATSU VERSES
UNITED STATES LANDMARK SUPREME
COURT DECISION [inaudible]
AND UP HOLDING.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ISSUED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP. FOR THE MUSLIM
TRAVEL BAN.
AND SO IN MANY [inaudible]
RESPECTS [inaudible]
THE LEGACY OF KOREMATSU WITH
TARNISHED [inaudible]
BY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER [inaudible]
IN BANNING.
THOSE COMING FROM.
COUNTRIES WITH PREDOMINANTLY
MUSLIM POPULATIONS ON THE BASIS
OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
INVOKING THE EXACT SAME
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE USED TO
JUSTIFY THE INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING WORLD
WAR.
TWO AND SO CLEARLY.
WE NEED TO LEARN.
AND CONTINUED TO STUDY MORE OF
LESSONS OF THE TRAFFIC UP SORT
OF THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
INTERNMENT AND THAT IS.
THE LEGACY AND THAT IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FRED KOREMATSU AND
THAT IS THE RELEVANCE TODAY
WHETHER WE'RE TARGETING.
MUSLIM AMERICANS AS NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS OR IMMIGRANTS
COMING FROM OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE LESSONS OF KOREMATSU
CONTINUE TO BE RELEVANT TODAY.
AS FOR THAT REASON I ASK OUR
COLLEAGUES TO A JOIN MESSAGE TO
AND SUPPORTING ACR.
THIRTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR SHE MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU AGAIN I ASKED HER FOR
THE FIRST ROAD TO BE OPEN POLL
CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU THE FIRST
ROLE WE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN
THE AMHERST THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE POSE SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS FOR FIVE AND SIX PASS
AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WILL BE HEARING AB ONE FORTY
NINE COOPER UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION ON MONDAY.
ON MONDAY IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT'S APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY.
UPON A GERMAN TO HEAR AB.
ONE FORTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN LIMON.
AND THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS MONDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTH IS GO RED FOR
WOMEN.
WEAR RED DAY.
CHILMARK AMERICAN HEART MONTH.
PLEASE REMEMBER TO WEAR RED ON
MONDAY.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY FEBRUARY FIRST NO
FLOOR SESSION A CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY FEBRUARY FOURTH THE FLOOR
SESSION.
IS AT ONE PM.
WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION A
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT THE
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED WHERE AT
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES WILL
BE JOINING THE MEMORY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE GERMANS IN
MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR. ONE TO BEGIN WITH
MISTER OR MURATSUCHI FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
I RISE.
TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES IN JOINING
MEET TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
OF THE VICTIMS OF THE CABLE
HOUSE BOWL SHOOTING INCIDENT.
IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF MICHAEL THIS SEAN
RADFORD.
AGE.
TWENTY ROBERT EARL MACON'S
JUNIOR AGE.
TWENTY EIGHT AND AT ASSN CARL
EDWARDS.
AGE.
TWENTY EIGHT THE GABLE HOUSE.
BOWL.
WAS KNOWN AS A TORRANCE IS THE
INSTITUTION.
AS A GATHERING PLACE. FOR
BIRTHDAY CELEBRATIONS.
CHURCH AND SCHOOL OUTINGS FOR
FUN DAY OF BOWLING.
EN A COMMUNITY THAT IS PROUD. TO
BE SAFE.
AND YET ON THE FRIDAY NIGHT
BOWLING LEAGUE ON JANUARY FOURTH.
THE GAVE A HOUSEFUL BECAME THE
SCENE OF A SENSELESS ACT.
OF GUN VIOLENCE.
I WANT EXTEND MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES. TO THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS [inaudible]
OF MICHAEL RADFORD [inaudible]
ROBERT MAKINS.
IN ASSN ADWORDS.
IT WAS THE LATEST INCIDENT IN
THE GROWING EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE.
THAT IS HITTING EVERY COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT ARTS OUR STATE AND
OUR COUNTRY.
I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THEIR MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK SILVA.
THE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MY FRIEND RUBY SANDRA MARTINEZ
OROZCO WAS BORN ON SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE TO
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND SAN
PEDRO CALIFORNIA.
LIKE ME SANDRA WAS BORN TO A
LARGE FAMILY AND SHE WAS THE
SEVENTH OF EIGHT CHILDREN.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM SAN PEDRO
HIGH SCHOOL CLASS OF NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE SHE MARRIED HER
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART.
AND NEIGHBOR LOUIS OR ROSCOE.
TOGETHER THEY HAD THREE
DAUGHTERS LUCINDA JESSICA AND
CHERYL AND THEY MOVED TO FULLER
TO IN CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO AND SANDRA WAS A STAY
AT HOME MOM.
AFTER HER CHILDREN GREW SHE
STARTED TO STUDIES TAILORING AN
FULLER TEN AND RECEIVED AN A A
AT FULLER TEN COLLEGE.
SANDRA WAS THE FIRST IN HER
FAMILY TO OBTAIN A COLLEGE
EDUCATION.
THERE WERE DIFFICULT TIMES FOR
HER AS LIEU WEEK PASSED AWAY
VERY EARLY HER HUSBAND AND HER
HOUSE ALSO BURNED.
ON FOURTH OF JULY.
BUT WITH THAT IN THE SET BACKS
SHE TAUGHT HER THREE DAUGHTERS
THE VALUE OF EDUCATION.
HARD WORK POSITIVITY AND ABILITY
TO MAKE THE BEST OUT OF WHAT
LIFE OFFERS YOU.
XANDER BEGAN HER TEACHING CAREER
AS AN INSTRUCTIONAL ASSISTANT
AND AFTER SHE RECEIVED HER
TEACHING CREDENTIAL THEN SHE
WENT BACK TO TEACH AT MAPLE
ELEMENTARY WHERE SHE ALSO
STARTED AN AFTER SCHOOL TUTORING
PROGRAM.
AND WORKED WITH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO HAVE THEM WORK AT
MAPLE SCHOOL AS TUTORS.
SHE WAS ALSO A BILINGUAL TEACHER
IN SAN PEDRO FOR SEVERAL YEARS
AND THEN LATER SHE RETIRED FROM
LA HABRA SCHOOL DISTRICT AFTER
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OF TEACHING.
IN ADDITION TO THAT SANDRA WENT
BACK IN ALSO RECEIVED HER
MASTER'S DEGREE AND BILINGUAL
LIBRARY SCIENCE FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON SHE EVEN AUTHORED.
A BILINGUAL BOOK.
WHICH WAS CALLED I WANT TO BOOK
KATO ALL ONE LIBERAL.
IT WAS WRITTEN FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
SHE EVEN WENT TO SPAIN TO WORK
WITH A CHILDREN'S AUTHOR.
ALMOST FLORIDA ADHA AN ISABEL
COMPLAIN.
AND WELL SHE WAS THERE SHE WROTE
HER OWN STORY.
SANDER WAS LOVED BY MANY IN THE
TEN SHE LOVE TO TRAVEL SHE WAS A
HUGE PART OF THE FULLER TEN
SISTER CITY WHERE SHE TOOK MANY
MANY TRIPS TO THE CITY OF
MORELIA.
SHE'S A GREAT FRIEND SHE LOVED
ALL PEOPLE AND THEY LOVED HER
BECAUSE OF HER CONTAGIOUS SMILE.
SHE WILL BE MISSED BY OUR LARGE
FAMILY AND MANY FRIENDS AND SHE
IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTERS
LUCINDA JESSICA CHERYL AND THEIR
HUSBANDS.
AND SHE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY MANY
GRANDCHILDREN AND BY HER
BROTHERS JESSE AND ROBERT.
AND HER SISTER LEILANI I ASK YOU
TO ADJOURN IN SANDRA'S IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA.
YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DEL YOU
A MERRY HERNANDEZ WHO IS A
CONSTITUENT MINE FROM FULLER TEN
AND ONE A PARK.
AND DALY WAS MARRIED ANA WAS
BORN ON MAY FIFTH IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR AND GONZALEZ
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS REYES DIDN'T
SIT.
SALINAS BUT ALSO SHE METHER
FUTURE HUSBAND AS SHE WAS A DISC
JOCKEY AND HE WOULD LISTEN TO
HER WAY BACK THAT WHERE THEY
WOULD RECORD SONGS AND HE WOULD
CALL IN AND REQUEST SONGS FROM
HER.
AFTER THEY MARRIED THEY MOVED.
TO ORANGE COUNTY MANY MANY YEARS
AGO AND D'ELIA.
WOULD THEN HAVE START A FAMILY
WHERE THEY HAD FIVE CHILDREN.
AFTER STAYING HOME WITH HER
CHILDREN AND TEACHING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING COMPASSION FOR OTHERS SHE
ALSO LED BY THAT EXAMPLE BY
VOLUNTEERING.
AT HER CHURCH HER LOCAL CHURCH
ST PHILIP BENEATH Z. --
WHERE SHE WAS ACTIVE IN HER
CHURCH AND VOLUNTEERED UP
THROUGH THE SOCIETY OF VINCE ST
PAUL BY DELIVERING BOXES OF FOOD
TO NEEDY FAMILIES HOLDING PRAYER
GROUPS PREPARING FOOD FOR
GRIEVING FAMILIES?
KNOWN AS THE MARTHA'S. FOR OVER
EIGHTEEN YEARS SHE MALISSE FOR
THE CHURCH'S ANNUAL CARNIVAL
DELIA SURVIVED BY YOUR BY YOUR
SISTER ANITA.
BY HER BROTHER ALEX HER TWO
YOUNGER SISTERS FRANCIS IN AND
FOR CHILDREN --
ROSE MERRY JIMMY ANNA AND IT DEL
AND EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND SIX
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN SO AGAIN WE
WANT TO THANK DEL YOU OFF FOR
HER KIND COMPASSION SERVICE TO
THE CITY OF FULLER TEN WE ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
D'ELIA.
MERRY HERNANDEZ.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS QUIRK
SILVA.
MR QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY
MEMORY.
ON FRIDAY NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PHILIP HOMES
FOUNDING MEMBER AND FIRST
PRESIDENT.
THE MUSEUM OF LOCAL HISTORY IN
THE TRI CITY AREA.
OUR PASSED AWAY IT IS HOME AT
AGE.
NINETY FOUR PHIL WAS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE HISTORICAL COMMUNITY
SINCE HE AND HIS FAMILY MOVED TO
THE TRI CITY AREA IN. NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT HIS FIRST YEAR
WORKING AT THE NEWLY FORMED
FREMONT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE SPENT HIRING TEACHERS FOR THE
EXPANDING DISTRICT.
PHIL HAD A PASSION FOR LOCAL
HISTORY RUN HIS MASTER'S THESIS
ABOUT THE LOCAL HISTORY THE AREA
WHERE HE GREW UP IN WASHINGTON --
TOWNSHIP.
IF YOU'RE MOVING TO FREMONT.
HE JUMPED RIGHT INTO PURSUING
HIS PASSION.
BY RESEARCHING AND CONNECTING
WITH PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE TRI CITY AREA.
WHO SHARE THIS INTEREST?
OUR FEELS PUBLISHING THE
RESEARCH DAYS WERE JUST
BEGINNING.
FELON DORIS ROSE WROTE
REFLECTIONS THE EDUCATIONAL
HERITAGE OF FREMONT.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE ALSO
WROTE MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
HISTORICAL ARTICLES FOR THREE
PUBLISHERS.
MANY RESIDENTS HAD BEEN TOUCHED
BY IS STORIES I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY DAMP DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES.
DEVELOPS HOME FAMILY AND FRIENDS
FILLABLE REMEMBERED FONDLY FOR
HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO DOCUMENTING
CELEBRATING AND SUPPORTING THE
STUDY OF THE RICH HISTORY OF THE
TRI CITY AREA THANK YOU.
THANK RISK QUIRK OF MR KANSEN
CHU YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZED ON THE
STREET GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SO
MEMBERS ALSO ASKED I WILL JOIN
IN MEMORY OF A MISTER PHILLIPS
HOMES.
MR HOLMES WAS A KEY MEMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
WHERE HE SPENT SEVENTEEN
COMBINED YEARS AS PRINCIPAL
FORMAT HOLES ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND COMBS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL?
THROUGH HIS WORK WAS THE LOCAL
HISTORICAL GROUP.
FILL TYLER'S FLEA WORK TO
COLLECT AND CATALOG SALTONSTALL
FOR HISTORICAL DOCUMENTS AND
PHOTOS TO ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT
LOSE KNOWLEDGE.
OF THE PAST IN ORDER TO ADD YOUR
AND THROUGH HIS PUBLISHED BOOKS.
AND HISTORICAL ARTICLES HE WAS
ABLE TO GIVE HIS NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS A STRONG SENSE OF
CONNECTION. TO THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH WE LIVE.
A FILL DESCRIBED.
LOCAL HISTORY IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO FIGURE OUT WHO THEY
ARE WHERE THEY CAME FROM AND
THEIR PURPOSE OF LIFE.
THIS IS WHERE YOU ARE AND THE
PLACE WHERE YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
CONTRIBUTION.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FULFILLS
CONTRIBUTION AND OUR COMMUNITY
ARE STRONGER THANKS TO HIS
LIFE'S WORK.
PHIL IS SURVIVED BY HIS THREE
CHILDREN.
STAN WEST AND CHERYL AND
GRANDDAUGHTERS.
CRISTINA HOMES ALONG WITH TWO
BROTHERS AND TWO SISTERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SHOW.
MR EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE TODAY WITH
GREAT SORROW TO ADJOURN.
IN THE MEMORY OF CATHEDRAL CITY
MAYOR GREGORY PETTUS.
ELECTED IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
MAYOR PEDIS WAS THE LONGEST
SERVING MEMBER OF THE CITY
COUNCIL.
AND THE FIRST OPENLY GAY PUBLIC
SERVANT IN THE CITY'S HISTORY
AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF CALLING
MAYOR PAT IS A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE.
DURING MY TIME AS MAYOR FOR THE
CITY OF COACHELLA WE OFTEN
COLLABORATED TO ADDRESS SHARED
WHICH I VALLEY.
REGIONAL ISSUES THAT WERE OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
MAYOR PEDIS WILL BE REMEMBERED
FOR IS PROGRESSIVE LEGISLATIVE
IDEAS.
SUPPORTING CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE FOR ALL PEOPLE.
AT THE SAME TIME WORKING HARD TO
BRING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO
CITY CALLED HOME SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE IF YOU'RE
SAVAK IT FIRST CONSTITUENTS
MAYOR PEDIS HAS A LONG RECORD IN
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
INCLUDING CREATING THE FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER PROGRAM FOR HIS
COMMUNITY.
BUILDING SAY FRAUD TO SCHOOLS
AND COLLABORATING WITH POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO HELPING THOSE WITH ADDICTION
PROBLEMS.
MAYOR PEDIS CELEBRATED IN
HONORED THE DIVERSITY OF
CATHEDRAL CITY.
BY FOUND IN THE HUMAN FIELD
PROGRAM AT PATRICK PARK.
THAT HONORS OUR FALLEN SOLDIERS.
ADVOCATING FOR THE FIRST.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
IN THIS UNITED STATES LGBT Q.
VETERANS MEMORIAL.
THE RECOGNITION THAT THAT WAS
DESIGNATED HIM HIS CITY.
THE CITY WITHIN A CITY.
RAISING THE FIRST RAINBOW FLAG
AT CITY HALL DURING CATHEDRAL
CITY LGBT Q. DATES.
AND PROMOTING CAPITAL CITIES
CENTURY CITY POLICIES WE JUST A
FEW.
OF THE EFFORTS THAT HE PUT
FORWARD.
MAYOR PAT IS ALSO WORKED TO
ESTABLISH THE CAPITAL CITY GAVE
BUSINESSES SEE ASSOCIATION TO
FOSTER SUPPORT GAY OWN AND GAY
FRIENDLY COMPANIES.
ALL THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
LOST A GREAT LEADER.
THE LEGACY OF MAYOR PEDIS HAS
LEFT.
ON THE MATTEL VALLEY WILL
FOREVER BE HONORED AND
REMEMBERED.
WANT TO SHARE A FEW WEEKS BEFORE
HIS PASSING.
I HAD A OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH HIM AS WE USUALLY MATT.
TALK ABOUT STATE RELATED ISSUES
HE HAD ONE SPECIFIC ASK OF ME.
AND HIS GOAL AS HE ASSUMED THE
ROLE OF MAYOR WAS TO PLANT ONE
THOUSAND TREES THROUGHOUT HIS
ENTIRE CITY.
AND FOR PURPOSES OF IN A
SEQUESTERING CARBON AND SHADE IN
AN AREA THAT HAS A HUNDRED AND%
TWENTY FIVE DEGREE WEATHER AND
AND I SAID TO HIM THAT WE WOULD
MAKE.
THAT HAPPEN. THOUSAND TREES
DROUGHT.
THE CITY OF CATHEDRAL CITY AND I
I CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER WAY.
TO IN A PROMOTE HIS LEGACY AN
HONOR HIM.
BY COLLECTIVELY --
IN OUR REGION PLANNING A
THOUSAND TREES IN HIS HONOR NOT
ONLY FOR THE GREATNESS AND
GOODNESS OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT TO COMMEMORATE HIS LIFE AND
LEGACY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ASKED WE GERMANS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING HEARING --
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES MISTER QUIRK
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY.
FEBRUARY FOURTH AT ONE PM WE ARE
ADJOURNED